mon invité estime que le français est
menacé partout y compris au Québec c'est
la ministre responsable des langues
officielles à ottawaï est en pleine
réforme une loi qu'on avait promis de
moderniser depuis très longtemps tout à
l'heure je m'entretiens également avec
Monsieur Jean-François Robert je vais
d'abord du côté d'Ottawa bonsoir madame
petit
on est chez vous on est bien accueilli
merci beaucoup écoutez vous l'admettez
sans réserve que le français est menacé
partout au Canada même au Québec
absolument je pense que les données du
recensement qui ont été publiées au
dernier nous démontre exactement ça ça
fait nous comme gouvernement fédéral
nous sommes le premier couvrement à
reconnaître se déclin et puis on doit
avoir une stratégie ambitieuse pour
adresser ce déclin voilà pourquoi le
projet loi plein d'action etc mais
justement ce projet de loi c'est très en
ce moment il fait grand débat à Ottawa
fait même du petit remous à l'intérieur
de votre partie mais dans les
communautés francophones comme
acadiennes que vous connaissez bien
surtout les autres ici là on est très
impatient une demande pourquoi ça traîne
autant les intervenants qui sont ici ce
soir et partout autour du pays me disent
ils sont vraiment impatients ils veulent
voir l'adoption du projet de loi dans
les plus brefs télé moi qui habite en
Acadie dans une communauté langue
officielle en situation militaire je
prenais l'importance de cette loi cette
nouvelle mouture de la loi va faire une
différence pour nous communiquer puis
c'est très important qu'on continue
d'aller là-bas puis faire suite qu'on va
faire qu'on va voir l'option plutôt que
plus tard et comment va faire la
différence mais réellement il y a des on
parle du déclin du français premièrement
avec notre avec notre nouvelle bouture
on parle d'une stratégie d'immigration
francophone encore une fois pour
adresser ce déclin du français c'est sûr
que l'immigration c'est une composante
qui est important mais partout mais
c'est sûr qu'on va l'avoir avec ça
l'autre chose aussi on parle des droits
fondamentaux à la justice sans le
s’assurer que les juges à la Cour
suprême du Canada vont être complètement
bilingue sans aide interprétation qui
est un autre option qui est super
importante pour les gens ça fait encore
une fois qu'on se comprend des
initiatives comme ça c'est du concret et
puis oui le gouvernement fédéral est
sérieux on est on veut aller là-bas on
va l'avant puis on va voir l'adoption
comme j'ai dit on espère bientôt il y a
des gens qui sont sur ce plateau et
d'autres dans les comités francophones
qui demandent seulement pourquoi
Ottawa quand Ottawa signe des ententes
pour les services de garde universel
pourquoi
Ottawan n'exige pas
certains montants une réserve pour créer
des garderies francophones ce qui semble
pas être le cas et ça inquiète pourquoi
vous l'avez pas fait avec une nouvelle
voiture de la loi quand même si tu
regardes le langage de la partie 7 etc
on veut vraiment s'assurer que tout est
décisions qui sont prises pour le
gouvernement fédéral peu importe on veut
s'assurer qu'il va toujours avoir une
lentille pour garder c'est quoi l'impact
de ces décisions si nos communautés
langues officielles en situation
militaire pareil comme les analyse
comparative du sexe on se demande ces
questions là depuis 2015 le cabinet très
de décision qui passe au cabinet on a
l'antilat puis en fait ça sur la même
chose pour s'appliquer pour les langues
officielles pour les garderies alors on
c'est des milliards pour les garderies à
travers le Canada mais on n'exige pas
d'assurer de la création de garderie
pour les enfants
francophones et ils sont peut-être
obligés à ce moment-là de renoncer alors
culture à leur langue pour commencer
leur éducation dans des gardeurs
anglophones mais encore une fois la
nouvelle mouture de la loi quand même
les langages et beaucoup beaucoup plus
fort pour s'assurer qu'on va toujours
considération des besoins des
communautés langues officielles en
situation militaire puis je pense aussi
qu'on doit vraiment regarder à toute la
question des mesures positives qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire comme gouvernement pour
s'assurer que si que réellement correct
l'égalité réelle le français et
l'anglais on doit prendre un doigt
prendre considération ces mesures
positives là pour faire avancer ses
dossier et puis comme il est langue
officielles je suis impatient comme tous
les intervenants qui sont ici ce soir
puisqu'on veut voir la loi avancée puis
après ça on veut voir un plan d'action
et qu'on travaille dessus qu'on va
déposer bientôt et dans ce projet de loi
c'est très vous êtes un peu en débat
avec ce qui se passe parce que la
nouvelle loi québécoise voudrait que
vous renonciez à exercer votre
juridiction au Québec sur les
entreprises de juridiction fédérale et
hier on apprenait que le CN acceptait la
nouvelle loi québécoise la nouvelle loi
101 le CN donc ils ont pourquoi vous
vous rendez pas à vouloir vous-même
exercer cette juridiction là faut faire
un petit cadeau au Québec ce soir
monsieur Robert des écoute et j'aime
beaucoup Monsieur Roberts
je pense qu'on doit prendre en
considération que moi je mets ce pied un
code fédéral national
moi je fais masturer que la loi qui va
s'appliquer au Québec dans les régions
francophones que cette loi là aussi va
s'appliquer ça fait le régime prend la
mission pied Anne-Marie quand même on
voulait s'assurer le régime était
semblable presque quasi pareil puisqu'on
veut s'assurer qu'il va pas avoir un
régime qui va plus facile que l'autre à
ce point ici la loi comme telle dit que
les entreprises privées de compétences
fédérales au Québec va avoir le choix de
assujetti à notre loi ou à la loi du
Québec mais encore une fois les deux
lois falling on voulait faire ce qu'il
ait peu avoir une cutter plus facile que
l'autre puis je pense ça a été mission
accompli est-ce que vous êtes bravo
moi je me dis pour toi les entreprises
en question qui vont être à cette loi
c'est une bonne nouvelle puisque encore
une fois on veut qu'il se responsabilise
on veut qu'il fasse leur part et aussi
pour adresser les décadis français merci
d'avoir été avec nous restez là on va
demander les réactions quelques
réactions du panel monsieur
est en train de dire c'est important que
toutes les communautés sentent que elle
aussi peuvent avoir des services en
français de qualité égale puisque c'est
pas le cas au Canada en ce moment je
travaille avec mes collègues de d'autres
provinces puis on voit qu'il y a une
énorme disparité entre les provinces
entre ce que les gens sont capables
d'avoir comme service en Ontario on est
plus choyé que d'autres il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire mais des
fois je confère aux gens qui sont en
Colombie Britannique ou dans d'autres
provinces c'est c'est presque honteux le
manque de service en français dans ses
provinces madame Roy vous parlez au nom
de millions de francophones 8 millions
virgule 8 millions au Canada 2,8 alors
si qu'il parle à Madame petit
je pense que Madame petit potée la
ministre a bien expliqué qu'est-ce qui
est dans la loi et encore d'autres
éléments de cette loi-là qui va faire en
sorte que on pourra peut-être renverser
le déclin la question de l'immigration
francophone
ça c'est très important la politique en
immigration francophone on va on va
toucher aussi cible et les cibles sont
très très importantes
pour avoir des bonnes signes des sites
qui vont venir réparer et en plus qui
vont venir augmenter le poids
démographique actuel mais dans les
mesures positives dont on parlait madame
la ministre il y a des éléments de
consultation et c'est là que c'est
important parce qu'on se demande souvent
les gens en général vont dire mais une
loi qu'est-ce que ça veut dire chez nous
mais quand on parle de de vous avez
mentionné les clauses linguistiques tout
à l'heure par rapport à la petite
enfance comment ça se fait que dans les
ententes fédérales commerciales
territoriales on exigeait pas mais dans
les mesures positifs d'en parler madame
petit potée il va avoir des exigences de
consultation donc quand il y aura des
ententes comme ça
les les provinces devront être
consultées et devront consulter leur
communauté alors madame un petit 20
secondes là-dessus oui la loi va dire
quelque chose quand elle sera adoptée
mais les contrats sont déjà signés dans
plusieurs cas vous allez revoir les
contrats c'est pas une question revoir
des contrats mais c'est sûr que nos
enfants bilatéral c'est ceux qui sont
toujours à négocier aussi on a dit
contraire pour 5 ans 10 ans fait que ces
choses dans vos continuer mais la loi
c'est longue officielle dernièrement si
vous me le permettez aussi qu'est-ce que
ça va faire aux communautés à
l'extérieur du Québec les régions fortes
en francophones pour des entreprises
privées en compétences fédérales les
gens pourrai travailler en français se
faire servir en français qui encore une
fois au Québec ça fait encore une fois
sept loi va réellement faire une
différence et puis je remercie tous les
intervenants qui sont ici ce soir
puisqu'ils ont travaillé d'arrache-pied
pour voir
vous buvez vous-même là alors je vais
joindre maintenant le ministre québécois
responsable de la langue française
restez là madame petit poteau
ce que vous avez dit bonsoir Monsieur le
Ministre ça va bien
bonsoir tout le monde à travers le
Canada dans la francophonie ça va très
bien
oui parce que le Québec avec sa nouvelle
loi aussi
un vrai temps de la main à toutes les
communautés francophones et acadienne
alors ça vous touche les propos vous
avez entendu ce soir sur le déclin et on
vous a entendu dire au début que oui on
courait vers le mur
il y a un déclin c'est évident et ça me
touche d'entendre ces personnes là qui
sont dans une posture de résistance de
vitalité de la langue française dans
toutes les communautés avec grandeur du
Canada juste à lui le travail de Madame
petit potée
il faut que la loi soit adoptée au
Québec on s'oppose absolument pas puis
on veut pas retarder l'adoption la
nouvelle Loi sur les langues officielles
on veut qu'il y a quelques amendements
encore on s'en est parlé directement
madame Petitpas et moi puis nos équipes
travaillent ensemble on pense que c'est
important qui est pas une option entre
une une loi qui exigeante la chambre de
langue française une loi qui serait
moins exigeante la Loi sur les langues
officielles pour les entreprises à
chaque fédéral donc il faut s'assurer
que quand on est un citoyen québécois
quand on fait affaire avec une
entreprise qu'elle soit à chaque
fédérale ou qu'elle soit proche fédérale
pour qu'il y ait le même standard de
français et moi j'ai confiance j'ai
confiance que Madame petit pour faire
les derniers ajustements et parce qu'on
veut qu'elle soit positive partout dans
francophonie canadienne on veut qu'elle
soit possible au Québec aussi cette
mais encore que Monsieur robertge même
malgré votre nouvelle loi la nouvelle
loi 101e bon il y en a encore qui
considère que ça ne va pas freiner le
déclin du français vous avez créé un
groupe de consultations avec vos
ministres en attendant un plan d'action
on attend des mesures comment ça va être
freiné le déclin du français au Québec
ou le français est quand même
majoritaire le poids démographique va
baisser c'est un enjeu démocratie
vous avez raison dire que le français
est majoritaire au Québec mais il est
menacé quand même et il faut le
mentionner là c'est pas parce que il y a
une majorité de francophones au Québec
que on est on doit s'endormir là-dessus
on l'a vu les chiffres des dernières
années l'ont montré français langue
maternelle français langue de travail
français langue parle à la maison en
français langue de communication tout ça
est un recul au Québec aussi et vous
avez raison on a ce moment notre groupe
d'actions pour l'avenir de la langue
française donc on est six ministres une
équipe qui travaille très très fort en
ce moment on se rencontre très souvent
et on veut accoucher d'un plan d'action
qui sera très très solide on va agir en
immigration en culture en éducation en
enseignement supérieur on a aussi la
ministre des Relations internationales
pour aller chercher des partenariats
dans la francophonie oui au Canada mais
partout sur la planète il y a encore
beaucoup à faire
d'ailleurs je vous ai vous avez annoncé
votre candidature pour l'organisation
internationale de francophonie on
connaît pas le ou la candidate
canadienne la connaissez-vous vous
non je peux pas
on verra la nomination voir si ça
monsieur Robert je suis au
Nouveau-Brunswick depuis trois jours
est-ce que vous devinez le sujet qui
fait jaser beaucoup ici
et je sais que ça a été difficile pour
nos avis francophones
parce que
ça fait beaucoup jaser ici vous voyez
que ça fait beaucoup mais peut-être pas
dans le sens où vous l'avez souhaité on
va écouter quelques commentaires on
écoute la pizza d'abord
le faucon pèlerin cet
oiseau de proie vraiment sec et reconnu
pour être assez chill parce qu'il est
super couic en vol il peut passer la
majorité de son temps à Watch et son
environnement mais malgré que c'est ce
qu'il est de chasse soit inside l'avenir
du faucon pèlerin de murs sketch
alors Monsieur Roberge les gens
rencontrés ici
estiment que cette pub est un peu
condescendante qu'elle joue beaucoup sur
une idée j'avoue avoir j'ai découvert ça
dans les derniers jours mais beaucoup
parlé d'insécurité linguistique et c'est
comme s'il y avait vu d'ici en tout cas
du mépris à l'endroit de la qualité de
langue qui est parlé ici le chien
pourquoi
je suis content d'avoir l'occasion de
répondre à cette question là parce que
c'est non écoutez c'est une question où
on était allé jouer sur l'humour parce
que quand on entend dans le cadre d'un
documentaire animalier on a d'habitude
d'entendre une langue
radio-canadienne si j'ose dire puisque
je suis à l'antenne et que là on entend
une langue où on est à moitié en anglais
à moitié en français ça a sucé des
réactions et ça me permet justement
d'aller sur les plateaux et de parler de
ce qui se passe avec la langue française
la publicité ne pouvait pas en vendre
quelques secondes parler la qualité de
langue parlée la qualité de la langue
écrite la qualité de la lecture la
langue parle à la Maison du français
parler au travail on pouvait pas traiter
de tout ça donc on est on a opté
peut-être pour une bouteille ça fait
réagir mais je veux pas que personne se
sente insulter l'objectif c'est de
parler du déclin en français vous faites
une émission spéciale une excellente
chose parce qu'on doit tous se mobiliser
tout se serrer les coudes il faut pas se
diviser là sur ce sujet
en même temps ce qui arrive c'est que si
la sécurité linguistique ça se résume à
ceci on parle tous français mais on a
toujours l'impression on a peur de
parler français parce qu'on a peur du
mépris du record méprisant sur la langue
sur le fait qu'on utilise des anglices
notre langue évolue c'est notre langue à
nous c'est notre chien qui on peut
parler alors
c'est pas sûr que vos propos sont
nécessairement convaincants pour ces
gens là
je comprends
intéressé par cet échange là qu'on
pourra continuer avec les membres des
communautés acadiennes par la suite mais
vous avez parlé de sécurité
linguistiques ça me touche parce qu'il y
a pas si longtemps je suis allé à
Calgary dans le cadre de mes fonctions
et j'ai parlé à plusieurs personnes des
gens de la communauté Franco à alberten
mais aussi d'autres personnes qui me
parlaient en anglais un moment donné
moi-même en anglais était parfait et
parfois j'utilisais des mots en français
je voyais qu'ils comprenaient mais à la
fin de la discussion si je vous parle en
français là vous ne comprenez puis me
répondait en français
est pas parfait je préfère parler
anglais il faut se décomplexer là il
faut être capable de parler français
même si on sait que c'est un parfait il
faut surtout pas sentir dans le regard
de l'autre le jugement ou dans le regard
du Québec ou d'un beau regard de
jugement pour celui ou celle qui
s'exprime en français puis je suis pas
parfait je suis prêt à pas être parfait
dernière question le rôle du Québec face
au reste du Canada il y en a pour qui le
Québec est écrasant il y en a pour qui
le Québec est un vaisseau amiral
un partenaire un partenaire on n'est pas
au-dessus des autres on est avec eux
d'ailleurs j'ai rencontré certains
intervenants
j'ai parlé avec plusieurs personnes la
communauté franco-albertaine on a une
politique de main tendue on va faire des
partenariats entre le Québec et les
autres provinces parce qu'on a des fonds
qu'on veut donner et on le fait en
partenariat pour soutenir les
différentes communautés francophones
parfois c'est des manifestations
artistiques d'autres fois c'est des
activités qui peuvent toucher
l'éducation la francisation on est on
est dans une démarche je vous dirais de
collaboration